I'm busy Myrna I'm 22 and I live in  Diavik here  i getcha missile I'm a waitress and I  heard around 20 euros a day  to me globalization means using modern  technology influencing politics and  taking part in all the new things taking  place in the world quite a show  vineet Cregan some of my ancestors and  relatives are Kurds some of my family  lives here in dr baqir there is a  conflict between Turks and Kurds my  family and relatives have been  persecuted and of course that's very  close to home for the planchette didn't  make the sub online oh yeah I'm studying  sports science and teach sports to  children that's a lot of fun I don't  want to keep doing it  me is finding it makes I'd like to go to  Spain and get to know the people and the  culture why don't you shoot over must  get that okay I don't really like to see  it doesn't cook known except I like to  sleep in my spare time but actually I  don't have a lot of free time  you  you